So today is the session.
I want to start with the
motivating reason before we continue with
the mathematics because in our last session
I don't think it.
we quite appreciated the
usefulness of
the topics we're talking about, you
know, the
Determinant of the Matrix eigenvectors. I
you know the stuff we talked about and I
think I should have started.
that session perhaps the way
kind of like what I was a
what I'm gonna do now.
so, of course if you remember the slides we said that we want
to work our way up to understanding this
thing called as yeah SVD and then
from there to PCA because
we know we said it has a very nice applications and
in particular.
I mean machine learning.
I want to this time just to make it.
You know.
more interesting start
not
from where we are going to be and then work our way backwards,
but partially I'm going to do that. So I'm going
to give you a very small insight into
machine learning
so we will kind of go into statistics for for.
It's a take a step in the
direction of Statistics briefly so we can
see you know, where PC could then help us with machine learning?
And then we will make this session of the session that comes on Friday
about SVD and PCA.
Okay, so first I'm going to talk about.
prediction
in machine learning
I should say prediction metrics. Okay, because
we're not going to go into machine learning just yet. That's
for module 4.
But just enough inside so that you know
say okay, this is okay. Let's
Let's see. What all this.
all this business hears about
Okay, so this is from the perspective of PC?
then we're going to
revisit the topics we talked about.
in our last session
So we will review it very quickly and then continue.
Covering some other topics that we did not cover and we
were meant to cover.
So once we are appreciate the
Purpose of what we're trying to do here in the context of machine learning.
We will then proceed.
to look at an example of diagonalization
diagonalization
of a matrix
diagonalization also known as eigen decomposition
You see this?
Is going to expose us to the topics. We're going
to talk about we talked about in
our last session.
And they will all of those will be prerequisites. So
this will be a prerequisite for
SVD SVD will be a prerequisite for PCA PC.
Will then be a prerequisite for us.
to
do two things reduce the dimensionality of our data.
and
increasing the or improving or optimizing the
prediction metric of our machine learning model.
So in order for us to look at this problem, we will end up visiting.
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
the characteristic polynomial
before he looked at this what this time it will
be a lot faster.
the inversion of a matrix
and
let me see if I've left anything out.
Yes.
To understand what this means we will also encounter a few terms.
something called basis
The basis is a set of vectors.
To which certain conditions to conditions apply?
and so we will talk about
a span
and
linear Independence
Okay, so these are all terms with which you must be
familiar.
and about which we must have Clarity in order to
you know.
Then talk about SVD and PCA.
Okay, so
in statistics
and let me call this.
file
machine learning
regression
we have different types of machine learning.
techniques
and
the fall under the following categories we
have
regression
classification
clustering
there is reinforcement learning.
the first two fall under the category
of supervised learning
We won't get into why it's called supervised right now.
Or why this is called for example unsupervised learning.
And also other odd supervisors learning
we have dementia reduction.
This is where PCA.
comes into the picture
reinforcement learning is about actions.
That optimize optimized Rewards.
So he we want.
train a model
or some sort of
machine
that can always
Do the right thing to maximize it what
for example, it's also using trading trading
algorithms.
to buy
a stock at the right moment still the stock
at the right moment.
Okay, so here we want actions that give
us the best rewards.
deep learning
Which really is Matrix operations
or it's fundamentally Matrix operate operations
implemented their python all the
machine learning models.
And all for all of these categories are implemented machine
in python or at least a popular ones.
You can also do these in r
and C++
and very
soon it will also JavaScript will
Encompass or be one of the programmable language
in which you can Implement these.
this we will leave for module 4, but once we understand
the how deep Learning Works we could
use neural networks to implement all of these
machine learning techniques
okay, let's
exclude these for the time being these are not this is all probability. This
is all Matrix algebra and multivariable calculus.
This is all.
probability Theory
So let's eliminate these for now.
We want to learn PCA to
do this.
So we can do that.
And do this very well.
Dementia reduction will allow us to find.
These things we call clusters which are how data is grouped.
You see sometimes you will have data that is properly labeled.
I imagine you have a data set of vehicles.
There is no mention of the
brand of the vehicle
But perhaps there is.
A categorization of the vehicle so
it can say truck.
sports car
then
bus, okay.
So that's label data.
Sometimes however, we will come across it that has no label.
And you have to group them somehow by
some sort of.
characteristic
now
if I say that a car has more than
four wheels.
You can say oh that's that's probably a truck, right?
Eight wheels or more Wheels if I tell you that a car has more
than four seats.
They have like I don't know 20 seats 30 seats or more you would
say it's a van or a bus.
So even though the label doesn't exist from the description you can tell.
What type of card this is?
Okay.
yeah, and yet you will come sometimes will come
across data that has no label and there is nothing discernible at
least not to you the
Statistician or data scientist like there are
so many features.
And these features not something about what you have domain expertise.
and so you will not be able to
a group that or cluster them
categorizing essentially.
Say let's say none of us had seen a car before.
or let's use
the aircrafts there are different types
of Passenger passenger flights double engine
single engine and let's say you do not know the difference
between the two. How would you go about grouping them?
And especially if there are so many things that describe them.
Well dimensionality reduction could help in
that process. It can reduce the features. So you have
less calculation to do.
Also now by the way dimensional reduction there
are multiple ways to do this SVD.
Is one of them PC is another one and there are
others like svm.
singular support Vector machines
So there are different ways to do this. So we're focused on
these two.
Okay.
Okay, so this will allow us to Cluster data.
when it is otherwise
very difficult just impossible to do.
but also allow us to
regression accurately another word for
regression is prediction or forecasting.
Let me give you a just enough.
Context so we can switch to PCA.
on the regression
and let me remove these for the time being.
simplify our
notes Here
There are different ways for you to determine the quality
of the prediction.
factor analysis
which category supervised learning or
otherwise learning
I'm not even sure I've heard this.
before factor analysis
Okay, so this is also dimensionality reduction.
I don't remember reading about this but I from a quick Google
search. This looks like a dimension I deduction problem.
Yeah, so this would also fall under.
unsupervised learning
Okay, so there are different ways to
calculate.
And empirically determine the quality of
a machine learning model.
There is something called MSC.
There is something called Mae.
And there's something called r squared.
A statistician would look at all three metrics.
So you're looking at the model from different
angles?
To make sure yeah, this this model is this.
Is doing a good job. Okay, that's a very that simplification,
but
At least when you implement this in programming.
after you train a machine learning model, we will
talk about this wood training and
we'll actually train about in practice.
You want to look at these metrics?
R squared is a number. That should converge.
2 1
The others are numbers that should
converge to zero.
in other words
You want all your r squared to be close to 1?
You want your ma and MSE to be?
zero, there's also something called RMS it
the root mean squared error, but
that's just the square root of of that.
now
these two way these two techniques are two ways
of
Calculating the error of your model.
So why do you want this to be closed at easier? Because the smaller
the
average error of the model
Well, it's predictions are closer to what has
actually happened.
Now this one uses squaring.
And this one uses absolute the absolute operation while
let me show you let me break down the equation for you. Okay
you are you understand, MC.
Me is what the purpose of it becomes
self-evident.
so in statistics
the idea of Statistics is to
look at
existing data
and a data is a collection of observations. So a data.
I want you to imagine an Excel sheet an Excel
sheet is data.
It's composed.
Of columns. Those columns are
the features. For example, let's say you're trying to predict the price of
a property.
In real estate, what are things that?
Influence the price of a property the size of
the let's say Apartments the size of the apartment.
number of bedrooms
the number of bathrooms proximity to
Amenities like supermarkets so nurse schools
and and even the city center.
Okay the club, for example, you're in
New York.
If you live in Manhattan, then the price of
properties are much more expensive than let's say if you were in that, New Jersey.
or surrounding surrounding cities Okay,
so
That's what we want to do. We want to learn.
Why certain factors influence a
certain outcome?
Okay, but let's keep it just let's keep
it minimum. So in in
The mathematics is this.
We use y for observation.
And there's a common chat. Would you use both or which one?
yeah, you could it's actually
you could use multiple techniques and then see which one
produces.
Which one is more effective and just like there are metrics for
regression.
So just like there are ways that you can measure the quality of
your forecasting. There are.
ways you can calculate the
the quality of the dimensionality reduction
the quality of our clustering. So if I if you remember that
breakdown I had for all of those techniques there's a way
you can measure their quality.
Okay, so why is the observation the word observation means
something that has actually happened?
An actual if we stick to the story of
a predicting real real estate prices observation
is an actual property that it exists in the
real world.
We use hat.
To say it's an estimate.
So basically we want to look at these observations. Let's
say we have 200 properties from these 200 properties. We
want to see why do one set
of properties cost so much and why do
these other sets of properties cost so little
So that we can produce estimates.
That is what it means to have a machine learning model
a model.
in
General terms it's something.
Is it some sort of mathematical expression?
That represents a real world phenomena.
Okay, so that for example, the price
of one property is a function of its size the
number of bedrooms, and it's proximity to the
city center.
Is the Hat also called a prediction? No, when you put the Hat
on top of the Y this whole thing becomes an estimate or prediction.
There are different by the way, and something we have to be
careful is that these words come with common different names estimate is
one of them.
Prediction is another one.
And even this one for example the why?
Okay, so specifically this response this
why represents the
the value of the observation
so why?
is actually dependent on except
One X up to
depends on x sub 1 x up to
where these X's are
You know features of the property size of the property number of
bedrooms and distance from the city center.
Okay.
So the observation or this is the value
this is the property value.
It's based on these features.
Okay without I'm not gonna show you the regression
model right now.
Okay, but what I really want to highlight is
this is this how we calculate MSE.
so
Yes, so that's the observation.
Let's say The observed.
property value
This is the estimated property value.
Okay.
what we want to do is this we want to
find the model.
Whose MSC?
Is as close to zero as possible, and this is how you calculate it.
so the function MSE
is given by
well here I'm going to
represent this as a
single value not as a function, but what we
do is we take the difference of
the observations
so we have y minus.
Hat why?
now, of course, we're not going to compare just
One single imagine an Excel
sheet, right one row is one property.
Imagine in your data set you have
1,000 properties
okay, and by the way
The way you would train a machine learning model is not to show the entirety of
the data. If we have 1,000 rows you would
show the model. Let's say 800 of them or 700 of
them.
So you would show the model 700 properties and
say hey model look at these 700 properties and
see if we can find out why one is expensive one. Why is
and why the others are not expensive?
Then to know if your model is actually learning something.
Who will take the remaining 300?
And use it to test the model.
So in other words, we're going to
compare.
The MSC the errors of 100 of
we're going to compare the those are the
model estimated versus the ones that the model the actual.
properties now, of course since this is these are going to be
collections of properties we will use uppercase letter y
Okay.
This is not a matrix. It's a random variable.
Just imagine it's a collection of
prices
okay, like a
list of prices. I don't even want to use the word Vector because I
don't I like I want to
separate terms and notation in statistics
and linear algebra, but imagine this is a set of
quantities so all of the retail prices
That are actually in our Excel sheet,
and these are the ones that model has predicted.
Now, of course you can see here.
If we take the difference.
In some instances they can cancel each other out.
because
maybe the price of one property is well.
500,000
the model predicted to be minus 500,000 so
they can cancel each other out. So
they're pretty to prevent this cancellation. What we do is we Square them.
We Square them.
But then but when you square the difference you blew
up.
The proportion so we have to then take the
square root.
of this Square difference
Okay. Now we are going to do this we will take
this difference for all of the observations.
So if we have n observations
we're going to do this for all so it's this is the mean average.
Okay, so that the difference between the observations and
the estimates. That's the error.
So the closer what the month the closer the actual observation
The observed property price.
The small the smaller difference between observed proper price
and the estimated price then the better the model is
at predicting.
The farther apart and the model, you know.
Doesn't has not really understood why one property
is expensive and the other isn't.
Okay, so we will do this for all of the properties.
and of course, this will be
We'll use the sub notation here. So this will be
some
for my
two and
okay.
We will get a single value.
The closer this MSC is to zero the better.
Now, of course, we will revisit this later on.
What does have to do with PCA?
long story short
PCA will make it easier for us to get this to zero.
By reducing the dimensionality of the data set.
and of course we'll have to
Like do the session on Friday and perhaps even revisit some
of the mathematics of PCA in the next session?
But PCA will help us get this number.
two zero
make it converge.
to zero
that's
one
example of what PC will get us
to do not only will I reduce the dimensionality so
you can use it for clustering.
You can also reduce the dimensionality to increase the quality of
your forecasting.
All right. Okay. Now we will develop this machine
learning section A lot there is I this is obviously
subject of its own that warrant its
own weeks, but
let's just keep this as our motivating reason.
to get
to take the data set.
reduce the dimensions
ultimately for the purpose of getting the prediction to
be you know.
at the best possible
A metric so this is MSC is one metric Mae is
another metric. So in Mae instead of taking the square root.
Of the difference you use the absolute value those two vertical bars.
They will produce very similar qualities, but it's
always good to look at.
These two different measurements. Okay, let's let's return to linear
algebra.
Okay.
and
let me show you one more thing. One more picture. I
did I think we saw this the
the other session
so
I'm gonna type PCA.
variance
I remember there was one very nice animation, but I'm
not gonna spend this I don't have right now, but but
I'll definitely show it on Friday.
what we want to do is we have
multi-dimensional data and what we want to do is
create two vectors two vectors that
are
positioned
In such a way where the data.
These data points which we call the observations are farthest
from each other.
Okay.
The father they are from each other.
the more
variance or the more there is the
more this vector.
explains
something important about the data
Now there's a missing link.
There's a missing link that requires some mathematical prerequisites to
see why PCA equal will
get us to a smaller MSE.
Okay, but in order for us to bridge this Gap we need to we need
to turn to our topic but PCA another
way to look at this is as a linear transformation. Let
me see if we can if I go to Wikipedia.
I think I saw it there as well PCA.
if you remember linear transformation
we said that it can take you from two-dimensional from 2D
to 3D or from 3D to 2D or from 2D to
2D but in a different
Arrangement like
we saw
I think it was in session today this today's session
seven or this is session seven session eight.
Excuse me. I think it was session six or seven where we
saw half the sheer Matrix or the sheer vector.
And then we also looked at an example of making one vector
perpendicular to another by the way that's also called
orthogonality. It's two vectors are perpendicular
to each other then in lineage. We'll
see where their orthogonal.
but
when we took that vector and we rotated in
the 90 degrees, that was a linear transformation.
So PCA can also be perceived as some sort of
linear transformation.
Where was that picture I saw?
Maybe was svm SVD.
SVD Wiki pedia
Yeah, this is what I meant.
So we are going to go from our data.
Apply Transformations these basically
our Matrix is going to be decomposed.
Into three matrices where each matrices responsible
for some sort of transformation this transformation.
This ultimate transformation is going to
give us these vectors which we call the principal components.
we will have
several principal components, but the most
explanation the most
Let me use simple words the most. Yeah,
the first Vector which
is the first principle component will.
Contain most of the useful information.
And then the second Vector less than that the third Vector less
than that, so.
And one another important detail is that these two vectors must
be orthogonal? So the
Angle must be 90 degrees to make them perpendicular.
okay, so this
transformation this reshaping
of
our
Data, and our coordinate system is quite allow us
to find these two vectors.
We get these two vectors then our life becomes easier
when we want to group data.
About what we Have No Label or make you
better predictions, but like I said, there's still a missing
Bridge here. I'm leaving out some details, but
we're going to fill it today and on Friday.
Okay.
For example these sigmas these sigmas
that you see these are the eigenvalues. So, let's see what they
have to do with anything.
Okay.
Let me show you how diagonalization works.
In the process we will see all of these.
And you will Define all of these.
Okay, I am going to open a new file.
This is number 11. This is number 12.
Let's create one called 13.
So you're gonna lization.
Yeah going all.
or
eigen
decompo
position
to mount
so
I'm gonna have to type the code because I didn't have enough
time to write in advance, but I'll make this as quick as
possible. Say we have a
square Matrix a
Okay.
Let me just copy some.
code to make this faster
I'm gonna copy this code for creating a matrix.
We have a matrix a
with the following
components
it's a square Matrix. So 2 by 2.
And it's scaler values are two two one. Three
two, two.
one three
two diagonalization this Matrix
is to decompose it.
or factory
and the factors will be will represent
what the following letters.
So if I scroll down here, it will become.
It will become this.
a will be the product of
three matrices p
D and P
transpose
let me double check that to make sure it's not.
the inverse
I think it's inverse so.
like that
so let me show you how to get P once we
get p we can talk about inversion so we can see how we
get this and of course the prerequisite for the inverse
of a matrix is
Elimination matrices which we talked to an LED
composition and then the for this we will have talked about
bases or basis.
and
well everything we just
listed in the agenda.
So the composition of a will give us these three
Matrix. So let's see how what are the steps that we need
to perform to get to this and through these
steps. It will revisit eigenvalues eigenvectors.
Bases right. So we want
to
fill the
check check the prerequisites before getting the
PCA.
Okay.
So the first thing we are going to do.
is
Get the characteristic polynomial.
And to do that we will need to determinant.
function
whose argument
is the identity Matrix multiplied?
By Lambda, let me write it down. So we
will have
step one
direct heuristic
Ali
normal
Let me add my own step because this is a
bit more.
compressed
the
Lambda
times are in linear algebra. I is
the identity Matrix.
And step two will be the characteristic polynomial.
So we have if you remember we said that the identity Matrix.
is
By the way, I have to remember to make this bold because the
notation is very important.
copy this
here
so the identity Matrix
since the Matrix a is a 2 by 2 the identity Matrix
here will be a 2 by 2.
It will be one across the main diagonal.
So I
will be this Matrix.
1 0
0 1
Yes, if we multiply the
scalar.
With the identity Matrix, what do we get? So we
have the scale of Lambda?
Whose value is to be determined? That's why this function called determinant.
We are trying to determine the the undetermined which
and that untermined is that Lambda.
a Greek letter
So what we will do is then we will take this identity Matrix.
multiplied by Lambda
Lambda
2 well, we know what we see what happens in Jupiter
notebook when you multiply the scalar.
product on the with the identity Matrix
just for clarity. I'm going to use the
time symbol
so multiply that skill and these will be replaced.
So we can put the scalar here next to
it. And this will give us a new Matrix.
But all the ones have now become.
Lambda
this
we will then put inside the determinate function.
Okay.
So they get the characteristic polynomial.
I think this is messy. So let me remove these and put them
somewhere where you won't see them.
I'll put them here.
Just get them out of your way.
So what we will do is we will take.
this Matrix
Okay, I just put the times just so you know that we're multiplying it
together. I'm just going to go and remove them again.
So we're gonna take this product.
subtract it from a
minus this Matrix a minus that
Matrix
the difference we will put inside the determinate function.
which will
output the characteristic polynomial which will look like
you will see what it would look like now so we have
we have the Matrix a
The Matrix a
minus
Lambda times
identity
this
will be the argument for the determinant function.
And this will be basically be well.
if you remember about the what we said about determinant, it
will be the
the product
of the numbers on the main diagonal subtracted by
the product of the numbers across other
diagonal but we must first take the difference of these two
matrices. So I'm going to take
Matrix a
matrix a
and if we subtract from The Matrix a
This product Matrix this new Matrix Lambda. I
this will become 2 minus.
Lambda
3 minus Lambda
so the determinant of that
this
expression
times
that expression minus this
component times that component and we
will get the following polynomial.
Which we call the characteristic polynomial.
so
skipping the product and difference and
Expansion stuff we will get Lambda squared.
Lambda squared
minus 5 Lambda
plus 4
that is your characteristic polynomial.
step 3
for step 3 we must
find the roots remember, this is the variable.
And we want to know what this will be equal to.
so to find the roots of the
characteristic polynomial this will be step 3.
roots
of
characteristic polynomial
so we just solve for Lambda and we
will get
two
lambdas
Lambda 1
will be equal to
and the other one will be
eigenvalue 1 eigenvalue 2
Those are your two eigenvalues.
Okay.
so to find the roots of the characteristic polymers to find the eigenvalues now
that we have the eigenvalues we can go ahead and
Find the eigenvector for our Matrix.
nuances should be negative 4 negative 1
That I make a mistake again which Steps
step one steps.
the roots of the Lambda squared
minus 5 if you have minus 5 then
so it'll be Lambda minus 4 times Lambda minus
5 would be the
factors of Lambda Square minus 5 Lambda Plus
And why does it say something different here? You know
what? I'm going to cheat?
Let's just double check. I'm going to copy.
this bit
and there's this very nice website called symbol that
I don't like to spend too much time.
on algebraic
You know manipulation. So I'm just gonna swap the lambdas with x.
And I'll tell this very nice website to solve Forex.
It's the double check. Maybe the mistake is here.
And all of the roots were the rules.
Yeah X so if we would if we move negative wanted
other side. Yeah, you want. Yeah. Yeah, it's
a good thing we check. Yeah. Well, I also
use up opportunity to show you simple. That's very
helpful in the situations like this.
Okay.
so stuff for would be
to Now find the eigen
vectors so
we have
this expression
step 4
find the eigen.
vectors
so we want
this equation
a
Lambda equals B
now
you may not be able to discern but
I'm gonna try to make the Lambda here bold.
So math. Yes makes it bold.
I don't I I don't think even I can see but this is
supposed to be the vector. It's slightly.
more dense
and those are the eigenvalues.
It's not that clear. Just let's keep that in mind. Okay, so a is
going to be a matrix.
He's going to be a matrix.
B is going to be a vector and this is the eigenvector
for emphasis. These are the eigenvalues. These must
go in there.
Okay. So how do we find the eigenvectors we
do this?
We take our original Matrix.
a
And we multiplied by.
a vector with unknown quantities
So the eigenvector whose values is
still not known?
Multiplied by so what do we put here? We put
X
sub 1 x sub 2
is a column.
This will then turn it into a system of
equations.
system of linear equations right because none of these
Are they're all I mean these values are raised
to the power one.
And this will be cool to the vector.
So we want to find the values for
x.
That will make this matrix multiplication. Give us
a vector 0 0
now, what does this if we were to
convert this into a matrix? What we what what would we get?
We would get the following system of equations.
So
expressing as
systems of equations
we will get
I think I
have a typo.
this might
the table is
to want to just so we actually want
a minus 1 Lambda
a minus 1 Lambda. So we want this Matrix multiplied
by the eigenvector.
So this should become.
A minus
the identity
Matrix
times
the vector Lambda
okay, because here we
Took the determinant of a minus Lambda and
the idea. Well, this is it. So
same thing we've done up here.
First we took the determinant of this Matrix.
now we are taking the
Now we're solving for.
the eigenvector
of this Matrix
Okay.
So this Matrix actually become.
two two one three
so two two
one three
and
see if I skip something here.
Yes.
so if we will take we have to choose one
of these well to find the eigenvector you
must
find the actor for specific eigenvalue.
So I will denote.
these as sub 1 and sub 2
Okay.
so these are
the
SE are the two Roots we found so let's first
solve for
let me make them. Let me make this two and make this one because I want
to follow the or sequence I have here.
Anyway, this is the first route. This is the second root.
Okay, so we're gonna find the actor eigenvectors for
Lambda sub 1
Lambda
sub 1
Which means that?
We must evaluate this Matrix. So
2 minus.
1 will make this
one
then this brings two.
This remains one and three minus 1 is
just two. So this becomes 2.
Okay, so this after we
plug in one for these?
Variables evaluate the expressions and
evaluate these differences.
And we will get this Matrix.
For the other eigenvale value, we'll have a different.
We'd have different components Matrix. Anyway, we
turn this into a system of a linear
equations. We will get
the following
to equations we will have
one
x sub 1
plus 2 times x Up 2
and of course equal to 0
And you will get the second equation.
And they will all be and since we also have one or two
down here. We also have the same.
system
So both of these equations are identical.
If you remember from our last session, we eliminated one of these so we
can just
take one of them.
and solve for
software X and Y
or x sub 1 and x sub 2
so x sub 1 excuse me x sub 1
would become
negative 2
x sub 2 if we do the algebra.
Will become one.
Okay, so, you know the whole story.
moving X up to another side
And then moving except one other side. We'll get these two.
We get these two routes.
So we don't need to have this repetition we can just keep one of those systems since
they're identical.
and solving
or
x sub 1
and X up to
now that we have x sub 1 and x sub 2 we will be know the components of
the eigenvector.
So we know we can plug in these numbers we can plug in minus 2
and minus 1.
in here
and so our Vector becomes
now here, we also need something called a basis. So we
need the eigenvector for
the first eigenvalid and the eigenvector of the second eigenvalue to
put them together inside the Matrix because we're
not just solving for the eigenvectors. We're actually
trying to get to diagonalization. So we're not quite done yet.
which is why I will create a
Vector here
So let's say denote the first.
eigenvector
And we will use V sub 1 so V sub
1 is going to be.
the vector
with the roots we have just found.
and oops the roots
are
negative 2 and 1
so negative 2
and 1
we will put this eigenvector and the second one
inside.
A matrix so these will become the columns.
of The Matrix
Why are you complaining?
That's step five is to of course find the eigenvector for
the second eigenvalue.
I'm going to skip the steps.
Just to save time.
I'll complete the steps after today's session
but when we solve for the second eigen.
Value which is equal to 4.
So I I can value top two
is the four eigenvalues of what we say is equal to 1.
We will get a second eigenvector.
V sub 2
with components
one one
okay.
With these two together, we can construct The Matrix. So let's proceed
to the next step.
step
Yes.
four steps six
There we go.
If I scroll up here to the beginning.
I remove the comment but we said that we want to decompose a into the
following matrices.
We said we want to decompose.
a to the following matrices, so we have a
equals
p
Which is going to contain the eigenvectors as
columns.
times d
And then the inverse of P.
p is going to contain the eigenvectors so p
where
p is the
Matrix
with eigenvectors
as columns
D will be the Matrix.
containing
the eigenvalues
for the eigenvectors
and
P to the power negative 1
is the invert is the
inversion of the Matrix this minus one
business by the way has a very nice explanation.
and it has to do with
Division you see we cannot we cannot perform division in linear
algebra. If you remember the axioms
that we talked about. I think we talked about the axioms of
vectors not the axioms of matrices, but anyway division is
not
what you can do what you can't do however is
multiply
by the you know, one over the
value. So for example, if you have a scalar three to
cancel it out.
It can multiply by one over three.
so
basically, if you have a denominator, excuse
me, if you have a ratio like like so
you know like
I want right now. But if basically if you have one over three, you can
represent us three to the power negative 1.
This is where the this is where the mind is one comes
from. So this should be minus 1.
minus 1
and why is it not appearing?
Why is it out of here?
Save the file.
There we go.
There we go. Okay, so
We have just solved this.
We have also actually solved that we actually solve this before
we did that.
And this I'll show you how it's the I'll remind you how it's done again.
So I'm going to scroll all the way down.
So we will take these together stack them into a matrix
and we'll get
the Matrix p
Okay.
so
step six
you will say
is
plugin values
or
Math, yes.
p and
D
d
so that means that
a
will remain what it is.
That's a
p
Will be the eigenvectors.
So that's negative 2 and 1 for their first column.
So
negative 2 and 1 for the first column
One and one for the second column so one.
and the one for the second column
if V sub 1 V sub 2 first eigenvector second
eigenvector.
and then d
will be the diagonal matrix containing
The eigenvalue so I'm going to set this all to
0 what were the eigenvalues again?
one of them was
yeah, the first argument value was one and the
second argue value was 4 so this will become one.
and four
the inverse of a matrix
Let me take you to Google Sheets to Google Images to show you.
Pictorially how it solved that's lengthy. I'm
not gonna we won't do it here.
But it's similar to.
LED composition
so P if had we solved for
it and we inverted it it would become.
Beautiful. They don't eat it's not here.
But let me show you how it's done. Let me see
if I can use some sort of online tool to invert The
Matrix P sub 1 would become.
To find the inversion to inverted Matrix. I'm going to
type in version of
Matrix
yeah, I think it was this picture
looked up.
so to
imagine imagine
trying to get a bigger picture. There we go. Imagine. This
is p
And we want to introvert it.
To invert this Matrix. We argument the whole
Matrix with the identity Matrix. Why because we
need to keep track.
of the
elimination process procedures
so this will become your
elimination Matrix
If you remember from Led composition that the L Matrix.
Is the result of all of the elimination matrices and
each elimination Matrix is going to contain one.
gaussian elimination step
So here, for example, we have how many steps to.
we take the difference of row two and Row
one plug that into road to we take
the
We take Row one multiplied by 3 out of two Row three
replace Row three.
So we go through a series of gaussian lamination, and we know that
we have eliminated the Matrix once our original
Matrix looks ends up
in row reduce row Echelon form.
You can see we've gone from
you know this leading one leading one and leading minus
3 to getting
once all the across the diagonal
but look what has happened to the original ident Matrix.
And as all of these components, what are these components?
all of the combinations
for eliminating this Matrix this
Is p to the power negative 1?
This is the inversion.
of that
Now I'm not going to go through a series of gas elimination to know what this is
and it's not even here in this reference.
So
I guess we could use pandas.
but
I'm just going to for the time being just for this because
we know
And I want to lose a lot of time call this.
inversion
of P
so the Matrix a
can be decomposed into these
three matrices three matrices multiplying we
get and you will get the original Matrix.
in the context of
SVD this
I give value is going to these this Matrix of eigenvalue is
going to be very important.
So one of the things that will help us get to the principal component.
Is that is there any more steps that is
the only step now?
So we have just we have reviewed.
The process I can decomposition so we have just gone
over that.
We have reviewed this in the process and we
have seen what it means to have a character's characteristic polynomial
and solve for the problem. And I have just shown you at least
pictorially how to get the invention of a matrix.
Now let's talk about the basis.
What this piece of set?
instead of vectors
But a set of vectors with special rules.
so
Let me see if I can explain a basis.
Related to this example. Let me just double check
my comments in here.
And we also need to talk about change of basis, but not
Just yet.
So I'm going to type it pieces.
you
okay, so we also want to talk about
orthogonal
vectors and other than normal
orthonormal
I just want to see if I can relate it to the example. We just looked at so
not an isolation
Okay, let me let me tell you what a basis is and then our related to
this example.
So let's save this.
secret another one
that's tutorial.
I've done.
You want to understand what a base is set
is.
It's kind of redundant to say basis set because a
basis we just say basis, but it is a set.
Let me bring you my comments. So my notes.
A basis is a set.
of vectors over RN
so
we have a set where V1 V2 VN are
all vectors.
And they are over orange. So that means that they're all the
same dimension.
So if we talk about a 2d space this will have two components.
Like X Y X Y X Y X Y. They will
be like a
n vectors in a two-dimensional plane
in order for a set to be a basis set.
the vectors must span
to span means that they must all have the same dimension.
If this RN is 3D if it's R to
the power 3 this must be three-dimensional. This must be through that
dimensional. This must be dimension.
awareness are two which is
two dimensional and
they all have to be two-dimensional.
And the second condition is that they must speak independent. Now
what is independent mean?
So let's talk about dependence and Independence.
dependence and Independence
so I'm going to give you the formal definition but
its I think more
helpful to see it visually.
So for two vectors to be dependent or linear
dependent.
Is for this condition to hold?
by the way, I also going to
cite every example
I have created a list.
Of books I've used.
For this entire course, I think
they will add up to.
Maybe six seven books up to this point. It's like six books.
I will list them in here. So there will be another file called references
when you see something like five.
You will know which book from which
book this has been borrowed.
This is from the
Outlines book I don't remember which page this is but I will I will
also indicate the page where you
can find this example anyway.
for a
set
to have vectors that are linearly dependent.
Is that you have these scalar values
a sub one is up to a sub 3?
If you were to multiply these scalars.
by these vectors
and the scalars do not necessarily have to
be zero.
You will have zero. So let me show you an example of an
actual example, of course Independence is when this is not true.
so
let me give you an example. So the example I have is.
I'll tell you what the examples.
page
so let's consider a
example of
a set whose vectors are dependent
Basis they must be independent, but let me show you
what it means to be dependent and then you will know what it is what it means
to be independent.
So an example under this topic
under this section.
And I will show you in python as well.
example one
say we have a set.
Whose vectors are all?
over R3
we have a set. Let's call it B.
And let me copy The Matrix snippet from
the other file.
And this Matrix?
and
three vectors, so it's columns are vectors.
And the values are as follows. I will.
type in
one one
two
one one two
Or let me use this other one. It's easier zero one two.
0 1 2 0 1 2
okay.
So B if I can
express it in a different way is actually a set.
Remember because matrices are sets. Yes.
We just use square brackets.
For convenience, but this is actually a set.
Another way to express it is as V1.
Okay, this is V1. This is
V2. This is V3.
Now you want to see if if these vectors are dependent or
not.
If they are dependent there exists scalar
values.
That will help make this condition that will make this equation
be true.
Let me go to numpy to recreate this.
A call after you recreate this example.
So according to my example here from this book.
These vectors are dependent because there exists.
three scalar volumes
and the values are one zero.
0 so in this example if we
plug in y a one for a sub 1
0 for a sub two zero for a sub 3 then
this expression will be equal to zero and
that is how we know that this
set B
is not a basis because it's vectors are dependent on each other.
Let me show you in Python.
And then I'll give you a pictorial.
Illustration so you know, why does what is actually
mean? So what's this? Why is this useful?
So I'm going to go to collab.
And I will create a new notebook.
Are we really we just need no pie for this example?
import numpy as NP
so we have three vectors. Yes.
The vectors are okay. There is V sub
NP dot array
the values zero zero zero
This one will be one.
And this will be all two.
Okay, the coefficients.
and that
linear combination by the way, this is a linear
company, make sure
When you add these killers in the vectors and add these products,
that's a linear combination.
so the skill is for the linear combination are
1 0 1 0
So the original equation or the equation?
or which we must plug in values are a sub
times V sub 1
and we do this for all the other.
factors
If this equation equals 0 then we
we have linear dependence.
so a Subs what one is zero as
one a sub 2 is 0
and
So is a sub 3?
I run this.
I think we'll get a vector whose values
are three, but that's just the nature of
numpy
But what we should have gotten is a maybe there's a method for
this but we would have gotten a scalar value. Who's
Could be that would be zero.
for
these vectors
All right. Yeah for these vectors now these vectors must be in
the same Subspace. They must be the same subsets or
be the subset, right?
B is a subset of which
Set it is a subset.
of our
to the power 3
Okay.
so
dependence and Independence
only apply to this subset or Subspace
if you want to use linear algebra terminology.
So if there exists any three scalars
or any end scalars that would result
in such an equation then we have dependence.
Assuming they're not all zero if they're also really will obviously
be zero.
Okay. So linear Independence is the opposite of
what we have just seen.
Now pick thoroughly.
Let me see if I can show you a picture. If not,
I'll draw it for you. It's very easy to do.
linear
dependence
versus Independence
vectors
You know Google can be really let down sometimes.
Yeah, here we go.
Let me keep this here.
I'm not so sure about that.
And let's see if there's
another one.
Just two dimensions.
Yes.
Here we go.
And can I give you a third one?
Let's take you to dimensions.
these two vectors
are dependent imagine.
that
the on the right hand side. We have one two-dimensional.
Cartesian coordinate and the other on the left. You also
have a Cartesian coordinate.
this is dependent why because
these two vectors
are are on one dimension despite this
being a two-dimensional plane.
When you put them together, let's say I think this Edition when
you add them together, they both fought on the same.
axis
What I'm trying to say is they don't form you cannot for example form.
a plane
The Plainfield a plane is for two Dimensions, right? You could not
form a plane with these two vectors. They are dependent on each other.
With this one you could form a plane.
so if your basis
contains vectors
Over r squared so all that's all the
all the vectors are two dimensional. So B is
two dimensional e is the dimensional
And when you plot them.
They both.
With both they could produce a plane.
Then they are independent.
the third example
where they will go into three directions
so if we have
a
basis with three vectors
and the exceed
or fall below the number of dimensions of that.
Set that basis. Well that said
then they will not form a basis.
Okay. Hope that makes sense. But if it doesn't
let me just let's just keep this simple example. This is
the this is dependent because they both
are on top of each other.
This one is independent.
Now this is not to be confused with orthogonal vectors
for two vectors to be orthogonal. They must
form.
an 90 degree angle
That's a separate thing.
Okay.
That's what a basis is. Hope that's simple enough.
Now let me return here. So we talked about bases. So
we said what a span is. So span is when you
have a set or all the vectors are in the same.
or of the same
dimension
and linear Independence is where there exists
no coefficient.
That would make with which you could produce a third.
Vector so for example
Let me show you one more.
Say we have another bacteria with.
one
one two
one one
one
two two one
You see with these three vectors, for example, you
can add these two together given some coefficients.
To get this third one.
Or it could take this third Vector multiplied
by some scalar multiplied by some coefficient and
this Vector multiply by some coefficient to get that one.
Or it could take these two.
Multiply them to together by two separate coefficients to
get that Vector. This is what it means to be linear dependent.
So you can use two vectors to create a third vector.
For this set to be linearly independent.
That means you could not lose your thing.
No matter how you add or multiply two vectors. There's no way you could
get the third vector.
this concept of the basis is yet
another prerequisite for
singular validity composition
You have two more minutes. Let me see if I can leave with anything else orthogonal orthon,
or okay orthogonal. Let
me see if I have comments in here from
four or thought
here
here, baby
Okay, there's only two minutes left. Maybe let's Wikipedia.
This is like a Gamble.
Either we get a good definition or not also normal.
Matrix
well, let's actually do it make it pictures right
also normal vector.
Yes, so in an orthonormal Matrix they are
well, they are let me tell you the conditions. First of all, they
have unit vectors, which means they
well, the length is 1
so that's what unit Vector is.
And they are also orthogonal. So
if you remember the
the example with the plotting of the vectors.
And where we used when we
converted from polar coordinate to Cartesian coordinate.
perpendicularity, basically, yes, if two vectors if the
vectors in this Matrix
become orthogonal
And they are unit vectors. That's an orthonormal basis. That's normal
orthonormal Matrix. So for
example, if you have a matrix whose vectors look
like that.
their orthography the former 90 degree angle
And they are the unit.
They are unit vectors. This is now so this
is the Matrix with oh with orthonormal vectors.
And an orthogonal Matrix if we
go back to Wikipedia.
Wait a minute. Are they synonyms?
Am I forgetting or?
They have a different meaning.
So apparently if we look at this PDF.
They seem to be synonyms.
And Wikipedia says they're synonyms.
I guess then the synonyms.
So I'm just going to put this in parentheses.
Okay.
so
Now that we've covered these Concepts. I hope
we can on Friday.
Use these words without having to explain them any
further.
Now I did promise to make.
The notes and iPad embarked and
file I will.
But yeah, hopefully come Friday
we can just jump right into as feet. We can
jump right at SVD and then we would like a few steps away from PCA. So
we covered the prerequisites or rather.
We briefly talked about the motivating reason for want
to talk about PCA.
Tomorrow I'll on Friday. I will give you a the mathematical.
example
but next week we will jump into.
the programming implementation so
we will use a library called psychic learn.
So a scaler numpy pandas together.
matplotlib
and then
the session that follows will get an attention flow because I
think now we're getting like we're almost
there with all the
prerequisite knowledge
Okay, everyone.
Thank you very much for joining me.
And enjoy the rest of your day, and I'll see you on Friday
for now. Take care. Bye.